[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es mal wieder einen Klassiker, nämlich die Donauwelle,
aber nicht ganz klassisch, sondern auf die Saison abgestimmt
- mit Erdbeeren! Also eine Erdbeer-Donauwelle.
Eine Donauwelle wird normalerweise mit Kirschen aus dem Glas gemacht.
Wie gesagt, heute eine leichtere Version mit Erdbeere,
vor allem mit einer leckeren leichten Creme.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal den Teig herstellen.
Ich mache die Donauwelle als Schnitte, also als eckige Torte.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch gern rund zubereiten
und einfach in meiner App euch Zutaten umrechnen lassen.
Dann müsst ihr nicht mitdenken;
einfach nur die Backform angeben, den Durchmesser eingeben
oder eben auch die Backform, wenn ihr sie doch eckig macht
und größer oder kleiner haben wollt, auch einfach umrechnen lassen.
Geht wirklich sehr einfach und vor allem könnt ihr selbst bestimmen,
wie groß oder wie klein die Torte sein soll.
Ich mache jetzt erst einmal einen Rührteig.
Die klassische Donauwelle habe ich mit einem Butterrührteig gemacht.
Diese hier mache ich mit einem Ölteig – geht ein bisschen einfacher
und wird einfach noch ein bisschen leichter. Dafür verwende ich
4 Eier, 200 g Zucker, etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt,
jeweils 200 g Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch, 350 g Mehl,
1 Päckchen Backpulver (3 TL) und für die Schokovariante 50 g Kakao,
etwas Buttermilch und 50 g Schoko-Drops.
Den Ofen habe ich schon auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt
und kann jetzt hier zuerst einmal die Eier mit Zucker,
Salz und Vanilleextrakt verrühren
– für etwa 5-10 Minuten richtig schön cremig.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse jetzt aus.
Da gebt ihr jetzt direkt das Öl und die Buttermilch dazu.
Wenn ihr keine Buttermilch habt,
geht auch normale Milch, Mineralwasser oder eine Limonade.
Beim Sonnenblumenöl achte ich immer darauf,
dass es ein sehr neutrales ist.
Da ist ein Bio-Sonnenblumenöl eigentlich nicht ganz so gut,
denn das schmeckt man später heraus.
Deswegen habe ich immer hier eigentlich das günstigere.
Das eignet sich dann besser zum Backen.
Kurz einrühren. [Küchenmaschine]
Dann kann ich jetzt das Backpulver zum Mehl geben.
1 Tüte Backpulver sind exakt 3 TL.
Ich messe es immer mit meinen Messlöffeln.
Ich zeige euch das auch einmal.
Also es wird praktisch immer so ein gestrichener TL abgemessen.
Ich gebe es dann in den Rezepten immer als TL an,
damit ihr, wenn ihr das Rezept umrechnet,
nicht mit 1/2 oder 3/4 Packung arbeiten müsst.
Deswegen ist die Angabe bei Backpulver
und kleineren Zutaten mit TL immer einfacher.
Dann wirklich immer so der gestrichene TL – der zählt dann.
[Musik]
Ich kriege das vermischt – so!
Dann kommt das Mehl mit dem Backpulver hier hinein,
wird kurz eingerührt. Da jetzt nur kurz rühren,
sodass sich das Mehl schön verbindet, aber nicht zu lange rühren.
[Musik]
Wie gesagt, backe ich das Ganze jetzt eckig
auf dem Lochblech mit der Dauerbackfolie.
Ich werde auch immer wieder gefragt,
wie ich meine Backrahmen aufbewahre.
Also ich baue sie tatsächlich immer auseinander,
dass ich so einen L-Winkel habe. So passen mehr in die Schublade,
in den Backschrank. Dann ist das Zusammensetzen auch ganz einfach.
Ich habe nämlich hier immer die kurze Seite, hier die lange Seite.
Ihr nehmt dann praktisch immer die kurze Seite aneinander.
Beim anderen Pärchen genauso – oder die lange Seite.
Aber ihr müsst immer kurz und kurz oder lang und lang,
sonst geht es nicht.
Dann im Prinzip die zwei Teile nur noch zusammenfügen.
Jetzt könnt ihr das hier aufziehen,
könnt hier außen auch das Maß an der Skalierung ablesen.
Ich brauche den gleich noch einmal.
Der Josh guckt schon so skeptisch „Was macht sie da?!“
[Lacht]
Das wird eine Donauwelle.
Die hat einen hellen und einen dunklen Teig, wie bei dem Marmorkuchen.
Deswegen brauche ich jetzt erst einmal den hellen Teig.
Damit es nicht heruntertropft, lasse ich es da.
Und zwar gebe ich 2/3 des Teiges in die Backform hinein.
[Musik]
Den Rest gebe ich hier dazu
– Kakao, Buttermilch und die Schoko-Drops.
Jetzt kann ich das hier kurz verrühren.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Musik]
Dann kommt der dunkle Teig direkt auf den hellen Teig.
Anders als bei der klassischen Donauwelle werde ich die Erdbeeren
nicht mit backen, sondern die Erdbeeren später in die Creme geben.
Also gebackene Erdbeeren finde ich manchmal gut, aber hier nicht.
Achtet jetzt nur darauf, dass ihr den Schokoteig
nicht als Klecks einfach nur in die Mitte gebt,
weil dann sinkt er nach unten und ihr habt in der Mitte zu viel,
sondern wirklich gleichmäßig darüber verteilen.
Dann könnt ihr jetzt eine Gabel nehmen
und hier einfach so kleine Wellen durchziehen.
[Musik]
Bei der klassischen Donauwelle muss man diese Wellen gar nicht machen.
Man gibt ihr dann einfach nur die Kirschen oben darauf und diese
drücken sich beim Backen hinein und dann entsteht da diese Wellenform.
Aber da wir jetzt keine Kirschen oder Erdbeeren mit backen,
musste ich natürlich eine künstliche Welle machen
– die perfekte Welle!
Das kommt jetzt in den Backofen und wird gebacken.
In der Zeit kann ich schon aufräumen.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Der Kuchen ist gebacken und ich habe ihn auch schon abkühlen lassen.
Jetzt kommt die Cremeschicht dran.
Ich mache jetzt, wie gesagt, keine Buttercreme,
sondern eher eine leichte Quarksahnecreme.
Im Prinzip ist es auch eine Mischung aus Donauwelle, Bienenstich
und Erdbeertorte – kann doch nur gut werden!
Ich nehme dafür 500 g Magerquark, 80 g Puderzucker,
1 TL Vanilleextrakt, 500 g Sahne, San-apart zum Steifschlagen
und 500 g Erdbeeren – diese werden gleich fein gewürfelt.
Dann nehme ich jetzt erst einmal den Quark in die Rührschüssel,
gebe den Puderzucker dazu, dann Vanilleextrakt
und die Zutaten kurz verrühren.
Wenn ihr noch so wenig Vanilleextrakt in der Flasche habt
- ich meine, da ist noch ganz, ganz viel drin -,
könnt ihr z. B. auch, wenn ihr Milch oder Sahne verwendet,
diese hier hineingießen, verschließen, durchschütteln.
Dann habt ihr wirklich den kompletten Rest.
Die Flasche hebe ich meistens auf.
Falls wir noch einmal auf Reisen sind,
dann fülle ich da mein Shampoo oder Duschgel ab.
Dann könnt ihr sie einfach immer wieder benutzen.
Die Zutaten kurz verrühren. [Handrührgerät]
Dann könnt ihr hier langsam die Sahne dazu geben
[Musik]
und mit San-apart steifschlagen.
Immer einen TL San-apart pro 100 g Sahne oder Quark.
Dann habt ihr das perfekte Verhältnis.
[Musik]
Wisst ihr, was da noch perfekt passt? Gerade fällt es mir ein!
Wartet!
Karamell. Ich nehme noch Karamelltropfen.
[Musik]
[Handrührgerät]
Und jetzt einfach steigschlagen.
[Musik]
So ist sie perfekt, wenn sie nicht mehr fließt.
Dann stelle ich sie kurz zur Seite.
Wenn ihr länger braucht, dann lieber in den Kühlschrank stellen,
aber wenn es nur 2-3 Minuten sind, kann sie hier schön stehen
und dann kann ich hier die Erdbeeren vom Grün befreien
und einfach fein würfeln.
Diese hebe ich dann nämlich schön unter.
Dann habe ich da die frischen Erdbeeren schön mit dabei.
[Musik]
Dann kommen die Erdbeeren da jetzt hinein
und werden vorsichtig untergehoben.
[Musik]
Dann kommt die Masse direkt auf den kalten Tortenboden.
Den Backrahmen habe ich jetzt auch nicht entfernt.
Der bleibt noch schön dran.
Ich kann die Masse dann glattstreichen
und die Torte erst einmal für 2-4 Stunden kaltstellen.
Also die Zeit solltet ihr euch auf jeden Fall nehmen,
damit alles schön kalt ist und durchziehen kann.
Dann kann ich danach nämlich noch die Schokoladenglasur zubereiten.
[Musik]
Ich finde es immer gut, wenn man den Rand noch so schön sauber macht.
Das sieht dann gleich professioneller aus.
Dann decke ich die Torte einfach mit so einem Tortenretter ab
und dann kann sie in den Kühlschrank.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Kuchen schön kalt
und ich kann schon die Schokoladenglasur zubereiten.
Da ich jetzt hier keine Buttercreme habe,
mache ich keine knackige Schokolade, sondern eher eine Art Ganache.
Ich nehme hierfür 100 g Sahne und 200 g Zartbitterschokolade.
Die Sahne kann ich aufkochen. Sobald sie kocht,
schalte ich den Herd aus und rühre die Schokolade ein.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt jetzt so einfach auch ganz kurz stehenlassen für 1 Minute.
Dann löst sich die Schokolade gut und dann rühre ich sie gleich durch.
[Musik]
So sieht dann die Ganache aus.
Um ein bisschen Zeit zu sparen,
fülle ich sie kurz in einen flachen Teller.
So kühlt sie nämlich relativ schnell ab
und ich kann sie dann auch direkt auf die Torte darauf gießen,
denn zu warm sollte sie jetzt nicht sein.
Ansonsten löst sich die Quarksahne auf und das wäre sehr schade.
[Musik]
Dann könnt ihr das hier lauwarm auf die Torte gießen.
Dann wird es später, wie gesagt, nicht so eine knackige Schokolade,
sondern eher ein weicher Schokoladenguss.
Jetzt ein bisschen verstreichen.
Bei der Donauwelle macht man ja typischerweise
noch mit einem Tortenkamm die Wellen rein.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr gern noch mit diesem Tortenkamm,
also mit der Teigkarte so eine Welle reinziehen, müsst ihr aber nicht.
Ich bin selbst noch am Überlegen.
Ich glaube, ich mache es - ist nämlich eine Donauwelle.
[Musik]
Um komplett an den Rand zu kommen,
könnt ihr dann einfach den Tortenrand bzw. Backrahmen entfernen.
Ich stelle die Torte kurz noch einmal in den Kühlschrank
und kann schon einmal die Erdbeeren putzen,
denn im Prinzip ist die Donauschnitte fertig
- Donauwelle / Donauschnitte / Donautorte / Erdbeer-Donauwelle.
[Musik]
Dann geht es jetzt schon direkt ans Dekorieren.
Ich ziehe die Torte jetzt hier runter.
Dafür die Backfolie einfach umschlagen und darunter wegrollen.
Auf dieser solltet ihr nämlich nicht schneiden.
[Musik]
Dann schneide ich jetzt gleichgroße Stücke.
Was ihr beim Schneiden beachten könnt
- dass ihr das Messer immer mal wieder mit einem Tuch saubermacht,
bevor der nächste Schnitt kommt und ihr müsst so ein bisschen sägen,
denn sonst drückt ihr die Erdbeeren nur nach unten.
Deswegen lieber ein paar Sägebewegungen.
Falls die Torte nicht gleich gegessen wird,
würde ich euch empfehlen, Tortenguss zum Sprühen zu verwenden,
damit die Erdbeeren so einen schönen Schutz haben und nicht austrocknen.
Falls ihr sie gleich esst, könnt ihr sie auch weglassen,
aber der Tortenguss ist im Prinzip vegan – er ist auf Agar Agar-Basis.
So kann man die Früchte ein bisschen konservieren.
Das ist wie ein Tortenguss, den man normalerweise kochen müsste
oder manche nehmen auch Aprikosenmarmelade,
erwärmen sie und streichen sie dann damit ein.
Aber wie gesagt, könnt ihr sie auch einfach so bespritzen,
eh, besprühen.
[Sprühgeräusche]
Einfach ein bisschen auf die Schnittfläche.
Dann bekommt die Erdbeere auch einen richtig schönen Glanz.
[Musik]
Die Donauwelle ist fertig.
Jetzt darf der beste Kuchenverkoster die Donauwelle probieren.
SIAMAK: Hi.
SALLY: Hallo! Der Siamak.
SIAMAK: Erdbeer-Donauwelle, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Lecker! Ich liebe sowieso die Donauwelle.
SALLY: Ja? [Siamak bejaht] Ja!
SIAMAK: Mega!
SALLY: Aber ich muss dich enttäuschen: Ich habe keine Buttercreme.
SIAMAK: Ah, egal! Da ist genug Sahne. [Beide lachen]
Auch super!
SALLY: Ich dachte, zur Erdbeere passt vielleicht die Quarksahne,
weil sie ist ja leichter.
Aber ich weiß, dass du auch meine Buttercremes ganz gern magst.
SIAMAK: Oh ja! Mit Fondant.
SALLY: Siamak ist der einzige Mensch auf der Welt:
Buttercreme MIT Fondant!
SIAMAK: Dann noch Sahne oben drauf.
Lecker!
SALLY: Ist gut?
SIAMAK: Donauwelle ist einfach Hammer!
SALLY: Ist der Teig auch schön locker? [Siamak bejaht]
Ich habe es selbst noch nicht probiert.
Also ich dachte vorhin kurz,
dass die Schnitte mir zu hoch geworden ist.
Erst hatte ich den Backrahmen auf 30x30,
dann hatte ich ihn doch auf 25x25.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich schön so.
SIAMAK: Das Verhältnis passt auch voll!
Auch die Sahne mit dem Teig. Wenn der Teig jetzt zu dünn wäre,
dann ist das zu viel Sahne! Also für mich nicht, aber für andere...
SALLY: [Lacht] Für normale Verhältnisse.
SIAMAK: Genau, für normale Verhältnisse. Aber so ist es perfekt!
SALLY: Ach, sehr schön! Das freut mich.
Deswegen eigentlich ein sehr einfaches Rezept,
eine kurze Zubereitungszeit.
Was am längsten dauert, ist einfach die Kühlzeit.
Da müsst ihr euch ein bisschen Zeit nehmen,
aber ansonsten ein sehr einfaches Rezept.
Vor allem passt es jetzt zur Erdbeersaison.
SIAMAK: Ich finde es sogar mit Erdbeeren besser als mit Kirschen.
SALLY: Ja? [Siamak stimmt zu] Das ist gut!
Ich glaube, viele mögen diese Kirschen aus dem Glas auch nicht.
SIAMAK: Vor allem, weil manchmal noch der Stein mit drin ist.
Dann beißt du drauf und seit dem mag ich es nicht mehr so.
Aber sonst mit Erdbeeren – ja!
SALLY: Sehr gut!
SIAMAK: Echt geil!
SALLY: Juhu! Also Siamak schmeckt es.
Dann schmeckt es euch hoffentlich auch.
Probiert die Donauwelle gern einmal aus.
Schreibt mir gern, ob ihr Donauwelle allgemein mit Kirschen mögt
oder mit Erdbeeren, vielleicht diese light Version.
Okay, light Version... Vergesst das Wort.
Das ist keine light Version, aber es schmeckt leichter als Buttercreme
und es fühlt sich vielleicht leichter an. [Siamak stimmt zu]
Das Rezept gibt es in meiner App.
Wie gesagt, könnt ihr das Ganze auch rund backen als Kuchen.
Einfach in die App eintragen.
Die App rechnet alles für euch hoch oder runter.
Ihr könnt auch einmal ein ganzes Blech backen.
Sobald mal wieder Schulfeste und Familienfeiern erlaubt sind,
ist das auch ein Kuchen,
den man einfach schön auf einem großen Blech backen kann
und in kurzer Zeit etwas Großes zaubern kann
- für Geburtstage, Hochzeiten, aber eben auch für kleine Portionen.
Viel Spaß!
SIAMAK: Eine Frage: Sind da Schokostückchen drin? [Sally bejaht]
Hammer! Habe ich gerade gemerkt.
SALLY: Hast du das gemerkt?
SIAMAK: Ich habe gerade den Schokopart gegessen und dann... Hammer!
SALLY: Backfeste Schoko-Drops.
SIAMAK: Mmh!
SALLY: Ich habe gedacht, so ein bisschen aufpimpen.
SIAMAK: Passt echt gut dazu.
SALLY: Ja! Sehr gut.
Ich mache mit dem Siamak noch Produktbesprechung
und Verpackungsabnahmen und Sarah macht die Bilder.
Bis bald. Tschüss!
SIAMAK: Tschüss!
SALLY: Magst du noch ein Stück mitnehmen?
SIAMAK: Gerne!
SALLY: Und für morgen noch?
SIAMAK: Auch gerne!
[Beide lachen]
[Musik]